Trascrizione: Elisa Vitale
Revisore: Chiara Anna Gagliardi
Buonasera a tutti.
Quando si parla di bilinguismo
normalmente lo si associa
ad un tema impegnativo
sul piano sociale e politico,
cioè quello dell'identità etnica.
Pur senza negare l'importanza
di questo tipo di approccio,
se ne può proporre uno alternativo,
che fa leva invece,
sui vantaggi cognitivi del bilinguismo,
in particolare del bilinguismo precoce.
Per capire in che senso si parli
di questi vantaggi
possiamo riferirci a un problema,
quello dello sviluppo delle lingue
e della loro capacità
di trasformarsi
assorbendo anche significati nuovi.
Come avviene questo processo?
Partiamo da un esempio.
Poniamo di avere una lingua iconica,
cioè una lingua che
come i geroglifici egiziani,
faccia riferimento
alle capacità rappresentative
e istituisca quindi un legame
di tipo figurativo
tra il segno, il geroglifico,
e ciò che il segno denota,
ciò a cui si riferisce.
E poniamo che all'improvviso,
per caso, per maggiore efficienza,
un parlante introduca in questo sistema
un segno convenzionale, arbitrario,
che non c'entra niente
con l'oggetto denotato,
come appunto la nostra parola "casa",
che non ha nessun legame di somiglianza
con l'oggetto di riferimento.
Come fanno i parlanti a capire
questo nuovo segno,
totalmente estraneo
rispetto alla struttura della lingua?
È evidente
che questa capacità di comprensione
è legata a un processo
che eviti ogni forma di interruzione
della comunicazione.
Se cioè il segno estraneo
può essere compreso
in virtù del suo rapporto
con gli altri presenti nel contesto,
allora chiaramente per chi sente
questo nuovo segno
non ci sarà nessuna difficoltà
a comprenderlo.
Quindi, abbiamo un duplice meccanismo:
il radicamento,
cioè il fatto che il nuovo segno
in qualche modo si radichi,
si ponga in connessione stretta
con gli altri presenti nel linguaggio
e usualmente utilizzati,
e la capacità di innovazione,
la proiezione in un altrove,
in qualcosa di totalmente nuovo.
Ecco, questo processo
dà origine a un meccanismo,
che possiamo chiamare
di flessibilità contestualmente vincolata,
per cui da una parte c'è il radicamento,
cioè il vincolo,
e dall'altra parte, invece,
c'è la capacità di proiezione
nell'altrove o nell'altrimenti,
che genera appunto, innovazione.
Per spiegare questo meccanismo
si avanza oggi l'ipotesi
che nell'apparato cognitivo umano
esista un sistema,
che viene chiamato "sistema triadico
di radicamento e proiezione"
che spieghi appunto
questa duplice capacità
di radicamento per un verso
e di proiezione per l'altro.
Di questo dispositivo,
di questo meccanismo,
fanno parte tre tipi di intelligenza.
L'intelligenza ecologica,
che è sostanzialmente legata
a dispositivi di rappresentazione
dello spazio
e a capacità di far interagire
il sistema percettivo
e quello dell'azione.
L'intelligenza sociale,
che è legata alla capacità
di rappresentarsi ciò che pensa
o vede un altro,
la capacità di entrare
nella pelle di un altro,
attraverso la quale
si riesce a costruire uno sfondo condiviso
a livello sociale.
E infine, l'intelligenza temporale,
legata alla capacità
di viaggiare nel tempo,
sia riandando con la memoria al passato,
sia anticipando con le previsioni
e con le ipotesi il futuro.
Questi tre sistemi di elaborazione
dell'informazione,
pur essendo tra loro estremamente diversi,
sono comunque accomunati da un aspetto,
e cioè dal fatto
che tutte e tre funzionino
appunto sulla base di un meccanismo
che per un verso radica,
àncora all'ambiente,
e per l'altro verso proietta
in uno spazio alternativo.
Di questo tipo di meccanismo
si servì in qualche modo,
e adesso facciamo molte volte riferimento,
Giacomo Leopardi,
che nel suo Zibaldone parla,
a questo proposito,
di visione doppia.
L'espressione con cui Leopardi parla
di questa visione
è talmente precisa e bella
che non mi azzardo neanche a riassumerla
e per questo la voglio leggere
direttamente:
"All'uomo sensibile e immaginoso
che viva come io sono vissuto gran tempo
sentendo di continuo e immaginando,
il mondo e gli oggetti
sono in un certo modo doppi.
Egli vedrà con gli occhi una torre
e una campagna,
udrà con gli orecchi
un suono d'una campana,
e nel tempo stesso
con l'immaginazione vedrà un'altra torre,
un'altra campagna,
udrà un altro suono.
In questo secondo genere di obietti
sta tutto il bello
e il piacevole delle cose.
Trista quella vita,
ed è pur tale la vita comunemente,
che non vede, non ode, non sente
se non che oggetti semplici,
quelli solo di cui gli occhi, gli orecchi
e gli altri sentimenti
ricevono la sensazione."
E quindi Leopardi ci parla
di un'immagine seconda
e di una strategia dello sguardo,
che in qualche modo riesce
ad alimentare e ad arricchire
ciò che vediamo
con le capacità della fantasia
e dell'immaginazione.
In questo modo, non si appiattisce
sulla realtà com'è
ma disegna una realtà
che è fatta allo stesso tempo
di percezione e di immaginazione.
E quindi ancora una volta
di senso della realtà
e di radicamento
e di senso della possibilità,
cioè capacità di proiezione nell'altrove.
Che cosa c'entra questo
con il bilinguismo?
C'entra, evidentemente.
Perché un bambino che già in età precoce
venga in qualche modo abituato
a utilizzare correntemente quella
che possiamo chiamare
la lingua del luogo, la lingua cioè
che esprime al meglio la storia,
i tratti distintivi
dell'ambiente sociale in cui vive,
chiaramente acquisterà
una maggiore capacità
di radicamento in questo ambiente.
Dall'altra parte,
la conoscenza di una seconda lingua
meno legata o legata
in maniera più indiretta
all'ambiente di riferimento,
lo doterà di quella capacità
già in età precoce
di proiezione nell'altrove.
E soprattutto, lo doterà della capacità
di scegliere
tra un doppio registro linguistico
e quindi di separare la parola
e il significato,
proprio perché dispone
della possibilità
di esprimere lo stesso significato
con più parole appartenenti
a linguaggi diversi.
C'è un altro aspetto che va sottolineato
per evidenziare i vantaggi
del bilinguismo
ed è quello legato ai processi
della comunicazione.
La comunicazione è stata
in un primo momento
modellizzata da Jakobson,
il quale forniva un modello
abbastanza semplificato
nell'ambito del quale
il baricentro era tutto concentrato
sul messaggio
e sul fatto che questo messaggio
dovesse passare
in qualche maniera inalterato
dal mittente al destinatario.
Si postulava dunque
che mittente e destinatario
dovessero agire all'interno
dello stesso contesto,
possedere ovviamente lo stesso codice,
tenendo presente anche il canale,
diretto, via telefono, via televisione.
attraverso il quale
il codice viene erogato e utilizzato.
Il presupposto
da questo punto di vista
era che non ci fossero frizioni
o ostacoli
al passaggio inalterato
del messaggio dal mittente
al destinatario.
Che questo sia un processo
estremamente semplificato,
al limite della banalizzazione,
lo hanno messo in evidenza
due studiosi russi,
un semiologo, Lotman,
e uno dei più grandi matematici
del Novecento,
e cioè Kolmogorov,
che hanno messo in evidenza come
in realtà ogni processo di comunicazione
anche il più semplice,
sia un processo di traduzione,
dalla lingua dell'Io
alla lingua del Tu.
E anche se questi due parlanti
parlano la medesima lingua
chiaramente i codici che utilizzano,
i sottocodici di questa lingua
che utilizzano,
sono non necessariamente identici.
Questo lo si vede molto bene
quando in italiano ascoltiamo
ad esempio la conferenza
di uno specialista in una disciplina
che non mi appartiene,
di cui quindi faccio fatica
a seguire i significati e i contenuti.
Ebbene, in questo caso
il problema di fondo
che viene evidenziato è questo:
che siccome i codici sono diversi
la parte del messaggio
che il destinatario recepisce,
posto che appunto
i codici non coincidono totalmente,
è quella più interessante,
cioè quella che caratterizza,
connota i tratti distintivi
del mittente
rispetto al destinatario medesimo,
cioè la parte del messaggio
che va persa
è proprio quella più originale,
quello che il destinatario non sa
e che il mittente cerca in qualche modo
di comunicargli.
Come si fa a porre rimedio
a questa carenza
nei processi comunicativi?
Prendendo atto del fatto,
dice Lotman,
che anche il processo comunicativo
più semplice
e più banale,
diciamo presuppone la presenza
non di due soggetti
ma almeno quattro
e cioè il mittente, il destinatario,
il modello del destinatario
che il mittente si deve fare
per potergli indirizzare
un messaggio mirato,
cioè che il destinatario
sia in grado di capire
e il modello del mittente
che il destinatario si deve fare
per rispondergli in maniera adeguata.
E allora, da questo punto di vista
è evidente
che lo sforzo fondamentale
deve essere quello
di diventare buoni traduttori
in modo da entrare,
in qualche modo,
nella testa dell'altro
e di indirizzargli un messaggio
che sia alla sua portata.
Allora da questo punto di vista
il vantaggio di un bilingue
è evidente
essendo abituato a scegliere
tra due registri linguistici differenti
in base alla loro maggiore efficacia
rispetto a una determinata
situazione comunicativa
in cui si trova,
il bilingue è anche più capace
di fare questa operazione
di entrare nella testa dell'altro,
del destinatario,
e di calibrare
un messaggio su misura,
adatto per la sua comprensione.
E quindi da questo punto di vista
il bilingue si trova
in una condizione migliore
sotto il profilo dell'efficacia
dei processi comunicativi.
C'è infine un terzo vantaggio
che è interessante e importante,
che oggi viene messo in rilievo
in particolare dagli psicologi,
cioè quando, diciamo, qualcuno dispone
di due registri linguistici
è evidente che nel cervello
questi due o più registri linguistici
sono attivi contemporaneamente,
ma l'uno non deve disturbare
lo sviluppo dell'altro.
Per cui, sostanzialmente
quando io utilizzo uno dei due
devo essere in condizione di disattivare
in tutto o in parte,
meglio in tutto che in parte,
l'altro registro linguistico
in modo che non interferisca
con quello che sto utilizzando
in questo momento.
Questa si chiama capacità di inibizione,
cioè la capacità di inibire
momentaneamente,
di bloccare momentaneamente,
l'efficacia di processi linguistici
o cognitivi di cui pur si dispone.
Perché questo aspetto è interessante?
Perché noi sappiamo
che soprattutto in età adolescenziale
c'è un doppio problema
che l'adolescente appunto deve affrontare,
da una parte la sua capacità
di aggregazione,
possiamo chiamarla di fusionalità,
cioè di amalgamarsi al gruppo
degli amici, dei compagni,
acquisendo quindi capacità
anche sofisticate
di relazione sociale.
Dall'altra parte però evitare
che all'interno di questo processo
di aggregazione
il soggetto si comporti come una pecora,
che segue pedissequamente
i comportamenti degli altri
e che magari per essere accettato
dal gruppo,
sostanzialmente ne ricalchi
i comportamenti, la decisione e le scelte.
Il tutto a prezzo, chiaramente,
di un processo maturo di individuazione.
E allora, sotto questo profilo
la capacità di inibizione è fondamentale
perché se la si acquisisce,
l'adolescente riesce sì
a inserirsi nel gruppo,
a emularne i comportamenti,
quando ritiene
che questi comportamenti
siano degni di essere riprodotti,
ma è anche in condizione di dire di no
rispetto a decisioni, scelte
o comportamenti
che non lo convincano,
bloccando quindi con un processo inibitivo
il passaggio dalla visione di ciò
che gli altri fanno alla propria azione,
e sostanzialmente
quindi rimanendo all'interno
di una sfera di capacità autonoma,
di decisione e di elaborazione.
Quindi, abbiamo visto, il bilingue precoce
è in condizione di acquisire meglio
la capacità di radicarsi nell'ambiente,
ma anche di immaginare contesti altri,
quindi di vedere e pensare altrimenti.
Riesce meglio a calarsi
nei panni del destinatario,
quando deve attivare
un processo comunicativo
e a scegliere la forma di linguaggio
e di espressione più efficace
ai fini della riuscita
della comunicazione.
E infine, è in grado di relazionarsi
con gli altri
senza per questo necessariamente
riprodurne pedissequamente
i comportamenti,
e quindi, diciamo,
unendo la capacità di relazione sociale
con la capacità di sviluppare
autonomamente
le proprie scelte e decisioni.
Sono tre vantaggi cognitivi fondamentali
per lo sviluppo e per la crescita
e se, come sembra
e come abbiamo cercato di dire,
il bilinguismo aiuta a sviluppare
questi tre meccanismi,
il suo vantaggio cognitivo,
al di là di ogni posizione etnocentrica,
risulta evidente.